get yourself into some Metro Redux let's
talk about Artyom and friends Rob you
look like you're holding the controller
I am are you gonna drive us here into
the hosts of forensic Reno because they
redid it
Reidy we do red dude it's like
apocalypse no hey this is isn't that a
cooking thing where you like cook stuff
down and you're like drew do we do on
top of or do you make a roux there you
go Ruri did we do it's only room 3 what
am I talking about nobody's nobody's
here to listen so Metro redux is Metro
2033 and Metro last light together in
one Xbox one PlayStation 4 with PC
package as well
mm-hmm yes as a matter of fact yes and
the one of the most important things is
the way Metro 2033 has been improved
visually and brought sort of up to the
Metro last light level
so now 2033 has the Metro last light
interface it now includes the the same
weapon crafting and there's there's some
interesting stuff too where you can sort
of play last light more in the style of
2033 in the sense that it will it will
sort of reduce the amount of ammo reduce
exactly redo yeah the ammo and and gas
masks and so on and sort of tweak the
experience so it feels more like a 23-20
33 experience what you have - it feels a
little bit more scant the resource again
a little bit more scary a little bit
more like survival horror I feel like
but then if but then you also can apply
the sort of the last light a little bit
more gung-ho aspect to Metro 2033 so you
can play both games in a way that more
or less they can feel the same
regardless of whether you preferred sort
of the 2033 style or whether you
preferred the last light style but more
interesting is is is the visual upgrade
to me at least because these are the
first game yeah at least with the first
game would last like you barely notice
if you're playing on PC for example
you're not getting a drastically
different different game and you're
getting essentially the same also just
outlash there's less so you can't expect
there to be leaps and bounds that
they're gonna be able to take for it by
2033 is a different the 2033 is
definitely a different
and if you were to play them back to
back and when I played them I you know
having played 2033 and last light in the
past I actually did this thing where I
was going back and forth chapter 2
chapter 2 chapter chapter 2 chapter 2
chapter 2 sort of look and see how I
like that moment you didn't like this
one when you go underwater and you're
like oh absolutely
it's probably really cold yes have no
idea how cold that stinky Moscow water
is I'm gonna guess it's pretty cold
considering there's lots of ice and snow
around um but and I'm no expert on
weather ology that's true you do not
have your weather ology degree you've
only taken a few online courses yes but
the the games do look you know and I
said this in the review and you should
go read the review but not now after
you're finished watching us important
what we're like you know I mentioned in
the review you know something I feel
very strongly about which is like
instead of it feeling like a game and
sequel it now feels more like you know
sort of like a walking dead ish kind of
thing where it's like here's the game
first part of the game and now here's
the second part of the game
this do they narrative Lee kind of
complement each other that way like this
does at the end of 233 do you feel like
last I picks up from it yes well last
light does pick up directly from the
others loss and have like a satisfying
ending so it does 2033 has a good ending
but also there's a choice at the end of
it there's a there's then it only ends
up last night only starts one way so
there's only one choice you made at the
end of right 2030 degrees
yeah the canon through line may be
different and I don't want to give
anything away of course but and it's
interesting last light was my favorite
game last year so which which always
seems to surprise a lot of people but I
really like the upgrades 2033 of there
are a couple things that I miss one is I
feel like the road the the Nosal ice is
the which one which is like that oh
sorry creature double no solace right
yeah got Blenheim I say no soul ice
you'll say no solace the Russian dudes
in the game say no solace I know my god
I'm kidding I'm kidding
okay so anyway so I liked I in some
cases I like the way they look in the
first game a little bit more they're
well they're a little bit more Oh dark
one a little bit more like furry
and well yeah being a little bugger but
there's your recovery and a little bit
more furry and they used to look a
little more creepy and alien now they
could mole rat thing going on yeah yeah
they look they look a little bit more
honestly they look like they probably
belong more in this world than the
original design but the original design
had that suave alien look at it that
freaked me out yeah and there are a few
other things like some of the gas masks
that 20:33 has that gas mask that has
the they have the than the night-vision
goggles that are attached that come down
yeah and I don't remember seeing any of
those in the in the Redux version but
you see those in the in the original
2033 and it's a really interesting look
Alvin and I kind of missed that while I
was playing read X's I don't remember
seeing any there but and of course some
people just like the look
the lighting is much improved but some
people kind of like that little fighting
because it was more high contrast yeah
and a little bit faker looking but they
kind of liked the you know beside by
side like you could really tell the
difference I got Rob's thing oh yeah I
guess you're seeing it on the screen
right now yeah I mean it's got a graphic
different matter is really awesome thank
God they got that but this is really
interesting like here's the original and
then there's sea sprite you know a big
difference you know presumably I had to
like this was not just a real simple you
know texture of plate that they had oh
yeah this is a place of money redone
like in a lot of cases um even a got
scenes like you know their their places
so so in the in Metro 2033 the original
like a lot of cutscenes took place and
showed you are him in the in the third
person and now everything takes place in
first alright I'm gonna keep it more in
line with how they did Metro last light
so another thing they did we talked
about this was how they seem to have
changed a lot of voice over as well a
lot of voice over and that are really
bothering me we we have this discussion
yesterday yeah the bit in 2033 where you
come across a kid and you put them on
your shoulders and kind of take them
home through the thing so video game
children look freaky most of the time
anyway
and often like kind of sound freaky too
because there are adults playing
shoulder Gould's playing children but
so like that unless it's a great model
in the way that it's like you the
proportions are just there always have
their own little adults Ryan John that's
like nine years old so wrong with you
this is no exception but that whole bit
like you come across the kid he doesn't
look like a kid he looks like a
miniature adult he sounds like a
miniature adult when he talks and the
dialogue makes no sense because he's not
saying anything a child would actually
say yo you got a plan to smoke I got a
do my [ __ ] taxes so there there you
go [ __ ] like that my wife's breaking my
whole I got cancer there are bits like
that that kind of stand out and they
stood out before now they stand out I
didn't really because oh just jumped out
yeah there you go
well yet what's so funny is like it's
clearly a you know a woman you know
pretending to be oh it's like old Parson
smart since Mel back but you know she at
least yeah Cartwright actually sounds
like a boy like Bob's Burgers ollie and
Andy are right you know the Silverman
sisters but literally so it sounds like
but they sound like bull
yes hey mister like come on over here I
know the way he's got this oversized
hippo it on his and his fantastic
russian accent that you just showed off
oh thank you oh you play this over the
hands hey mister how are you know it's
me a child [ __ ] unbelievable child
like so now I can get New Jersey Oliver
Twist so there yes I are we talking
about a game I forgotten bakery we're
doing I think we're reenact Susie's I
just want to see this [ __ ] up kid now
I don't think we're gonna I don't think
we're gonna get there in this it's quite
a bit ahead of this is this worth
something playing for someone you could
we could actually do it I would you guys
I think you know on Xbox one I mean we
want to check out this new menu I think
it looks great
we'll just watch that for like two
minutes total loading times life look at
that there's a human and I didn't
mention this in the review I don't one
of those little things that kind of
bothers me as you go through is that you
find
diary pages
that you pick up now in most games
you're picking up other people's like
remnants in and here you're picking up
your own things yeah and so it doesn't
make any sense like what did you do go
to all these places beforehand and
spread your diary and then you're going
through and also why did you be picking
your diets like why you know what's in
it
you're we're oh no that's right you're
lightning from your own words this
doesn't make any sense aren't you
picking up a piece of paper and then
maybe taking a moment to do a diary
entry is that what it is like stalker so
I like found some paper in a quiet
moment I'm gonna record some of my
thoughts not like how the game
represents it it's just like you you
just pick up a dossier right there and
pick it up like oh that's so here's what
I was thinking if all if I hadn't read
this I would never have known the
contents of my own brain but other other
like obviously I think both I think 2033
is quite good I think blast light is
really everything remains X we're having
some fun at the game's expense but I
think this is one of those situations
where like you know there's a few weird
things that sort of stand out to you or
fun to talk about but like overall these
are excellent games and this is like a
really great way to play them Oh totally
and one of the one thing I like about it
I like you know I had a kind of a
difference of opinion in terms of like
the pervading darkness and whether that
works to the to the game's advantage or
not but but I really like and and this
comes as no surprise to anybody that
knows how much I love Dark Souls but I
love this kind of atmosphere anyway but
one of the things I really love is it
it's not cheesy here it's not I mean you
spend a lot of time simply existing in
these places and when people talk and
these guys have these Russian accents
they kind of sound you know they're
always looking a little bit they're
always telling like little jokes are
always just trying to get a little bit
of humor in there and it feels like okay
these guys these are guys who have lost
hope but you know a little bit of vodka
a little bit of a little bit of making
fun of things and you know maybe they
found a reason to push through this yeah
they've got this like this flinty humor
of that's like you know they there's a
defeated heir to the
but they're still just like well that's
my world it's like well you know let's
go on and see what's going so what do
you do what do you think about that girl
over there huh you know and of course
boobs
so if you're into that there's there
some is any hasty boob is babes redo
it's really no straight-up they are like
I'm gonna play the same I play the scene
and then there's a girl walks by you're
like oh she's got big ones huh I draw
the Redux and you see it and it's like
she even looks at you oh no yeah then I
can the pletely read I go guys you
didn't put that in the ground I
embarrass him just like back and forth
across that a few times it's really
thank you for your restraint Rob it's
really yeah the game does this whole
world has sort of a really interesting
women don't um have much more to do in
this in this world right tunnels they're
just kind of sitting stationary in
cities where you can interact with them
a little bit making weirdo babies um you
know strong woman in in last light but
it's it's not a role that is really
fleshed out or even accompanies you for
long instead you just hang out with a
guy named Buddha Boone bourbon bourbon
is fun
I think bourbon is really fun is it
bourbon like the like the drink are like
the chocolate biscuits no it's like the
drink nerds
it's like we'll drink what you don't get
that reference either that's it no Danny
I have no idea what you're talking about
understand Irish biscuit my Eve I know
about Irish people I learned from the
Assassin's Creed trailer great so yeah
yeah shape guys accents legit Shay
Patrick Connor or whatever his name is
not cover she has recorded it is Cormac
Cormac yeah he's got three first names
that's like calling somebody like an
American character Billy Joe Bob or
something make any sense how far away
from this weird kid are we wrong don't
stay on the oh that's right Jesus Christ
die
yeah he was showing you an everything
and you're like blah blah blah blah
Irish people I wasn't my fault that he
[ __ ] killed his friend that's true
that was Rob's fault he just could just
ran straight through the tripwire oh
well oh well don't do those two to see
the weird kid why don't you guess Metro
last
like we do for yourself that's right
yeah that's right you're like the K
don't know where it is I can't find it
there's there's the creepy moment with
the kid and the kids all creepy oh say
the creepy moment with the kid cat but
then you say that
so it's mental retail you fall down a
hole Xbox one ps4 PC 50 bucks 50 bucks
it's 50 bucks yes yes it's 50 bucks
sorry
now next week like we got a week early
we get to talk about it like yeah we get
to talk about it like a whole week early
good job cool like so good for us we get
to play in you down right yeah whoa took
a turn there Kevin yeah hey thank you
for I like to lord it over others thank
you rob thanks fern nobly trying to get
us to see a weird kid but instead just
yeah buddy oh well
you